oh these judges with the verdict that
could spell trouble for Boris Johnson
the advice given by the government to
Her Majesty the Queen to Parov
parliament from 9th September to 14th
October was unlawful and that therefore
the propagation itself is unlawful
Scotland's highest court ruled his
suspension of the Commons was an
unlawful tactic to fist rate Parliament
the case heard in Edinburgh after more
than 70 parliamentarians decided to take
on mr. Johnson in the courts if they
couldn't in the Commons this was a plot
by Boris Johnson Jacob Riis morg and
others to prevent us representing our
constituents views and to prevent them
apprentice scrutinizing them as they try
to take us through a backdoor towards an
audio brexit and so we feel utterly
vindicated mp's anger at full volume in
the early hours of Tuesday morning as
the government shut the doors and shut
down any debate in this place Labour's
shadow attorney-general clear that if
Parliament cannot check mr. Johnson the
courts must nobody is above the law
Boris Johnson and his mates have been
getting away with some very bad behavior
for a very long time and so today's
ruling from Scotland is very very
important push back indeed a former Tory
Attorney General thinks mr. Johnson was
check himself if Prime Minister's go
around misleading people whoever those
people may be then they should consider
their position
I don't consider it's an acceptable
situation when the government pays fast
and loose with the truth just finally
you think he should resign
under certain circumstances yes the PM
responded but not to journalists instead
taking pre-selected questions from
friends on Facebook how do you explain
to the British people that you are now
the leader of an authoritarian regime
why is homegrown authoritarianism better
than EU rule well am i must respectfully
disagree with you and your
characterization of this government
we're trying to do is implement the
result of the 2016 referendum he had one
ally at least in Nigel Farraj smells to
me of judicial interference any
government particularly with a new prime
minister and a new cabinet should be
able to put forward a queen speech so
what happens next the Scottish courts
have ruled that the five-week suspension
of Parliament is unlawful but the
governor will point out that the English
courts ruled only last week that it
wasn't so who's right well it won't be
up to Boris Johnson to decide that that
will be left to the highest court in the
UK it will be decided here at the
Supreme Court and the showdown when it
comes next Tuesday will be hugely
significant these MPs not prepared to
wait return into the green benches to
demand Parliament be recalled
immediately but this a symbolic show
this place silenced for now MPs
determined it won't be for long Beth
Rigby Sky News Westminster